Путін тепер буддизький монах
Папа Франциск зустрівся з дияволом
а Вілл Сміт знову побився на оскарі
звичайно ж усі ці картинки фейкові
створені штучним інтелектом Утім на
перший погляд вони справді схожі на
реальні фотографії
і багато людей вважають їх правдою і
реагують на них емоційно
як приміром у цьому випадку
у Франції чоловік похилого віку під час
протестів проти пенсійної реформи нібито
був до крові побитий поліцією
стверджують інтернет-користувачі
фотографія стала вірусною багато хто
гнівно реагував ганьба для Франції пише
одна із користувачок але давайте
поглянемо на фотографію уважніше загалом
усе виглядає доволі постановочно
Зверніть увагу на візори поліцейських
шоломів
цей неприродно перекриває голову іншого
поліцейського А цей у голову літнього
чоловіка
краплі крові на рукаві і на кисті
поліцейського також виглядає не
натурально
це фото згенерував штучний інтелект
Що До речі доволі просто
треба зареєструватися зробити кілька
кліків задати кілька ключових слів і
Дуже схоже на справжнє фото фейк готовий
для цього навіть не треба вміти
програмувати
генератори штучного інтелекту такі як
міджорний далі або Deep a самі все
роблять тому штучний інтелект нині
повсюди
нині ми спостерігаємо вибухове
збільшення генеративного контенту та
генерованого контенту
Я б сказав Нам слід звикати до того що
не можна довіряти жодному зображенню в
інтернеті але що буде якщо ми не знаємо
що правда А що ні в мережі
це може змінити наші погляди на
навколишній світ приміром якщо політичні
партії почнуть використовувати штучний
інтелект у своїх передвиборчих кампаніях
правопопулістська партія альтернатива
для Німеччини оприлюднила буцімто фото
збіженцями застерігаючи про драматичних
хвилю міграції
про що тут ніде не сказано фото створив
штучний інтелект
користувачі Інтернету та чекери
швидко розпізнали штучно згенероване
зображення наприклад занеприродніми
головами вухами пальцями та очима Гаразд
але як дізнатися чи справжнє зображення
чи його створив штучний інтелект ось
шість порад номер один придивляйтеся
уважніше щодня ми бачимо в інтернеті
десятки якщо не сотні зображень на
деяких ми затримуємося лише на
мілісекунду та з кролимо далі І тут
виникає небезпека не побачити
маніпуляцію якщо сумніваєтеся Подивіться
на картинку уважніше та збільшить її
Наприклад Це зображення Папи Франциска
він що і справді у дизайнерському
пуховику багато хто вирішив що фото
справжнє як показує це опитування у
Twitter але це фейк
при збільшенні зображення видно що
пальці правої руки дещо викривлені і не
тримає чашку
якось Зливається з окулярами
ці деталі видають роботу штучного
інтелекту
номер два шукайте джерело походження
фотографії Іноді у коментарях під постом
вже стоїть звідки та чи інша фотографія
А іноді варто провести зворотний пошук
щоб знайти оригінальний пост та
дізнатися більше про картинку Так ми
вчинили наприклад з цим вірусним фото
тут нібито зображений арешт Дональда
трампа що явно фейк зворотний пошук
цього фото привів до різноманітних
checking вони викривають цю фотографію
як згенерований фейк
але обережно на жаль не всі системи
зворотнього пошуку знаходять джерела
картинок штучного інтелекту
номер три звертайте увагу на типові для
штучного інтелекту помилки генератори
зображень поки що на щастя все що
роблять помилки інші ознаки - це часто
неточності у рисах обличчя
зокрема асиметрія приміром вуха
виглядають зовсім по-різному
також характерно окуляри та сережки
також часто виглядають деформованими це
видно на ці фейковій фотографії ми
створили її за допомогою рендом Face
generator будь-хто Може тут за лічені
секунди згенерувати зображення такі фото
часто використовують у фейкових акаунтах
номер чотири звертайте увагу на
пропорції тіла на багатьох зображеннях
штучного інтелекту пропорції тіла
неправильні або руки надто короткі або
пальці надто довгі або ноги надто великі
та широкі це видно наприклад на цьому
згенерованому зображені президента РФ
Володимира Путіна який нібито стоїть на
колінах перед лідером Китаю сідзеньпіном
ця картинка фейк фото створив штучний
інтелект нога фейкового Путіна надто
велика на знімку є й інші типові помилки
вуха фейкового деформовані
руки людини на задньому плані Зливається
№5
Перевірте чи не виглядає зображення
штучно або надміру глянцево
багато фото штучний інтелект генерує у
схожому стилі найбільш явним доказом Що
видає автор складних джунглей є для мене
естецький блиск або одинка на картинках
що швидше за все є ознакою згенерованого
зображення воно ніби згладжує шкіру
неприродним чином це створює такий собі
пластиковий ефект наче все виглядає
гіперреалістично сяючий барвисті
естетичного Та звісно ідеального
освітлення Так виглядає багато картинок
штучного інтелекту навіть ще
екстремальніша ніж фільтри в соцмережах
наприклад Ця жінка жодних плямок на
шкірі зморшок шрамів чи родимок але ця
фейкова картинка все ж таки має один
дефект на правій руці лише чотири пальці
і порада номер 6 перевірте тепло
зображення часто помилки закрадаються на
задньому тлі картинок штучного інтелекту
Як на цьому фото з актором Віллом Смітом
фейк це тепло на
ньому порушено глибину різкості реальних
фотографій
тут він виглядає неприродно ніби штучно
розмитий іноді програми планують людей
та об'єкти на задньому плані тож На Це
теж слід звернути увагу але важливо
відзначити що генератори на основі
штучного інтелекту швидко
вдосконалюються та постійно розвиваються
Я можу назвати вам ознаки на якій варто
звертати увагу сьогодні але немає жодної
гарантії що ці ознаки ще будуть
актуальні завтра деякі зображення
створені штучним інтелектом дурять
навіть професіоналів цей знімок переміг
на церемонії Sony World фотография вордс
Але німецький фотограф Борис відмовився
від нагороди бо створив це зображення за
допомогою штучного інтелекту він хотів
перевірити чи здатний журі фотоконкурсів
розпізнавати підробки А що з детекторами
штучного інтелекту чи здатні вони
викривати фейки програма hacken Face
одна з таких програм але часом і вона
помиляється як у цьому випадку це
означає що штучний інтелект поки що не
може розпізнавати штучний інтелект
тож все залежить від нас ми повинні самі
бути пильними та вміти розпізнавати
фейки
Напишіть нам про ваш досвід з фейками у
коментарях або електронну поштою факт
чекінг собака dw.com
[музика]